好 當年余晨是跟趙華一起創辦理財達人秀的
首帶的IP製作人就是陳余晨
後來他離開我了跑去考分析師
考到分析師了現在很厲害
專研的是PCB的領域
讓我們來歡迎余晨回來
趙華姐好
好 我可以很簡單的講一下
余晨曾經跟我們是作戰的夥伴
對不對
也有曾經大吼大叫流過眼淚的那一種
我們一起創業
要講出來
對 結果呢
她跟我的好姐妹婉婷跑了
她去了統一頭顧研究PCB
最後也從婉婷那兒跑了
因為去了老王跟普惠頭顧
喜歡的是普男
所以我們跟婉婷的感情
就變得更好了
對
余辰當然就是專研PCB
非常讚
我剛才已經先看過你的資料了
今天要來很獨家的講一件事情
坊間恐怕還沒有什麼人討論
當然就是Vaya Rubin她出貨
重點在揮答這一次晚上
會不會一反前十計
講完之後不要再跌了
還有PCB的規格拉滿
有一句話叫無步化
有一個新的材料
你已經研究好了
全系列你幫我們搭配了
會漲到台廠的誰
有沒有哪一些台廠要留意的
好 那先從這個NVIDIA
這次的表現來看
因為過去大家對於NVIDIA
都會有點擔心
就好像股價都漲在前面
然後財報過後呢
就變法會嘛
因為現在你看台股
這幾天法會也很多
NVIDIA這一次會不會變成法會
其實我覺得這次可能有一些不一樣
原因是因為這次的NVIDIA
在股價前一陣子這幾天
已經跌過了
所以我覺得這次可能會稍微
稍微有一些扭轉
再來就是說
NVIDIA的氣氛也慢慢在改善
因為大家知道說
它的財報應該表現不會太大問題
對 應該很好吧
絕對好
重點是在於說
接下來第四季
因為市場上會期待NVIDIA
在展望的部分
去交出千億美元的營收
那因為它第三季已經900多億了
所以你說挑戰千億美元
有沒有可能
我覺得還是有可能的
因為這個出來了
這個就是Valrubin
Valrubin開始來了
給微軟了 也給鴻海了
對 陸陸續續開始交貨了
那最近其實我們從供應鏈
也在聽說就是很多的組裝廠
都在搶說第一個要出Valrubin
所以從Valrubin的需求來看的話
應該沒什麼太大問題
所以我覺得在NVIDIA的展望上面
應該會表現不錯
好 等於之前大家一直很擔心
Viarubin出貨會不會有地顏什麼的
可是他就是在財報公布前宣告順利
對不對 現在順利要量產
對 所以而且從Viarubin
順利量產之後
大家就會有個氣氛
什麼氣氛
會開始想說
下一代
下一代他的會
他會變成什麼樣子
因為現在已經2026年下半年了
對
那接下來2027年下半年
就是他新一代
下一代的規格要推出了
那所以說現在市場上
其實也不是在討論
Verra Rubin的量產
這麼喜新研究
已經沒有在討論這個
大家都在討論
新的Verra Rubin
Rubin Ultra的規格
這Ultra的規格到底是怎麼樣
所以大家就會開始去翻
但你可以看到像
剛剛王伯講的像800VDC
好像這個CPU題材
好像最近這些新的東西
又全部活過來
原因就是因為現在市場上
開始去期待說
Rubin Ultra
能夠帶來我們一些新的驚喜
那這些新的規格裡面
有哪些東西
我們從新的研報
Semi-Analysis的報告裡面
他告訴我們一個關鍵字
他說這個關鍵字
PTFE
PTFE要來了
你看他說NVIDIA
他說計畫在Rubin Ultra的
NV Switch
這Switch版裡面他要使用PTFE材料這一家廠商這家演奏機構Semi-Analys機構最近的寒水會結動寒水會結動之前有掃過記憶體
它也打過光通訊
但它現在是支持PTFE的嗎
應該說PTFE這件事情
傳言很久了
然後被它這麼一講
現在市場上的聯想又開得起來
所以大家開始講
找這關鍵字PTFE到底是什麼東西
是什麼東西
沒有 我們先去找誰受惠
他就開始去找
就一直瘋狂亂找
就是說這個台場裡面
有PTFE是誰
可是他寫無部
所以看起來等一下
有點部的事情
會有一些聯想
那重點就是在於說
這張圖它是台虹官網的截圖
台虹的官網最近的標股
台虹官網它就告訴你說
它現在用的是PTFE型的CCL
它有在做這件事情
然後它是用無波纖的設計
來去做這件事情
你可以看到台虹官網
它揭露的這個疊構
就是說它的整個材料的疊起來的結構
就是說它用這個PTFE
就上下兩層就像夾三明治一樣
直接用PTFE就夾兩個這個附銅上面
就可以來當作是CCL囉
那大家有沒有發現
好像少了什麼東西啊
它取代的就是中間這個波纖層
因為過去CCL它中間就是用波纖層
來去做核心
可是台虹它告訴你說
它有辦法直接用PTFE
來去做核心
然後疊了複銅之後
就變成CCL基板
那我們就要來想說
這到底合不合理
有沒有可能
好 先想有沒有可能是不是
對 所以我們要去來研究一下說
PTFE到底是什麼東西
那PTFE它的化學名字
不用記了 就是聚四浮乙烯
好 你自己記就好了
對 可是大家在生活中
都常常在接觸這個材質
其實這個聚四浮乙烯
它就是不沾過材料
因為四浮乙烯
它有一個非常強大的特性
就是說它的摩擦力非常小
所以我們在把它用在
電子材料上面
有兩個很重要的係數
就是這個DK跟DF
我們之前在講說
銅箔基板最重要的
就是這兩個數字
因為你DK跟DF越小
就表示說訊號在上面
跑得越順暢
那這個阻礦越小
訊號越低
對於訊號的完整性
當然就越棒
所以你要去做銅箔接著上面
會稍微困難一些些
你表面要做改質
這是一個困難點
第一個
那再來就是說到後段的時候
假設你全部解決了
送到後段
那因為PTFE這件事情
這個材料它比較偏軟
那所以你知道在PTFE的時候
它加工它也一樣
它會受到熱脹縮的影響
它熱脹縮比較大
會導致說它的尺寸會有偏移
因為它的表面比較滑
所以它比較難做
然後再來就是說這個磚孔的部分
它容易磚的不夠漂亮
因為我們講說磚孔的品質
要磚的乾淨
那但是因為它比較軟
所以你可以想像說
這個東西它被磚孔之後
可能表面上面就會殘留一些些
的一些雜質之類的
所以知道PTFE這件事情
對於早期啦
早期對於PCB來講
是一件很麻煩的事情
可是現在的狀況來
就是說現在NVIDIA
它的因為傳輸的需求很高
那你至少先傳輸需求要到
再去講後面加工的問題
所以就會有開始說
有一些想法出來
那這個想法呢
我們就會
就是我們可以來講
來想一下
就是這個概念有點像在主套餐
主套餐的原因是因為
我們在講說
M9CCL
大家很常常聽到這個名詞
那我們講說CCL的三個
主要大原料就是
樹脂 波線布跟銅箔
那這個概念是說
我們要組成一個
M9等級的CCL
它其實是可以在樹脂裡面升級
它也可以從波線布裡面升級
它也可以從銅箔裡面做升級
我就幫大家組幾個套餐不是 這個菜單有點複雜啦好愚蠢 對那我就直接幫大家組好因為像這兩個就是第一個跟第二個這就是目前的現行目前的方案其實已經成熟的
對 這是已經很成熟的方案
就是大家要知道嘛
就M9數值加上薄線布
那薄線布你可以選LowDK
或者可以選Q布
那但是銅箔都一樣喔
要用HVLP4喔
好
這是目前最成熟的
那這樣子的做法
目前成熟方案有什麼優勢
當然就是成本上面非常棒嘛
非常成熟
那如果你把它換成Q布的話
那你當然就是機械性會再更好一點
但是這樣子目前這個成熟方案
也開始面臨到一些物理瓶頸
就像我前面講的
你的這個低損耗低阻抗的這個要求
慢慢的沒有辦法滿足客戶的需求
所以客戶就會試試看說
把PTFE加進來
那這PTFE加進來
它就可以把PTFE把它加在數值裡面
把數值變強化
那可能還是有這個還是有薄線部
可能還是一樣要用通過
這是一個方案
那這個就是一個相對於比較
距離比較遙遠的一個過渡方案
因為目前市場上最完美最完美的方案
當然是最下面這個
最完美的方案就是
你就直接用PTFE當作核心層
那我就直接把這個填充物加進去
但是我可以再配上HVLP4
這樣子做成一個是沒有波線部的
沒有波線部的一個CCL
所以大家就知道了
Q部 拜拜
Low DK 拜拜
還不能這樣說
我還不能這樣說
因為各有所好
每個客戶各有所好
但是其實最完美
最完美的解決方案
當然就是在性能上面
是最棒的沒有錯
性能可能性能超級強
可是成本會很難加
會拉到比較高
很難加工
然後成本會超級的貴
所以這個時候
市場上就會有一些衡量了
所以我們可以來說
可以來找一下
按照這個邏輯
我們可以來思考說
誰會受惠
好 有沒有絕對受惠
當然說這個
台虹跟雅電
PTFE是一定會受惠
做得出來就絕對受惠
對 因為現在市場上的邏輯就是說
這個PTFE它只是用的多跟少的差別
就像我剛剛前面那幾個方案
你只是用的多一點的話
你就是全部都是取代
全部都取代薄線布
那用的少一點呢
就裡面還是有薄線布的成分在
所以台湯跟亞電它的受惠程度
它一定是最直接的
而且它一定會受惠
那這個受惠幅度很有可能非常大
有可能非常大
因為它是一個從沒有到有的東西
想像空間極大
大家可以回想一下去年
食音部是不是這樣子
可能獲利都沒有開出來
就飆到翻
對 可以回想一下
像之前建設
我們講Micro Channel League的時候
是不是這樣子
那這樣從沒有到有的這個階段
是法人最喜歡的
所以這個法人
為什麼投信最近在買
就是在買這個夢想
但是CCL的部分
聽起來好像PTFE
跟CCL跟波線部有點打到
可是其實他們也不是說
完全全部都取代
他們有可能是並存的
尤其是CCL
它有一個殺手鍵就是有M10
M10比較就跟這個沒有關係
對 因為你如果有M10的話
其實客戶他還可以選M10
他不見得要選PTFE
他就變成說是一個各種的方案
在讓客戶選
所以我們從這個個股來看的話
像台虹跟雅電
這個創新高了
對啊 就是不管營收有沒有出來
他就先創高再說
對 那我覺得這個短線上面
還會有題材
這短線不會那麼快走完
你可以想像一下
像去年時音部
得宏 也走一大段
像Micro Channel 建設也走一大段
所以這個短線拉回
都還有機會可以再讓你上車
那以這個CCL來講的話
龍頭廠 抬光電
這個一定還是會
反正它全部的套餐它都可以
對 你說對
它就是一個很神奇的大廚
它什麼頂級套餐它都有
所以它的龍頭廠 抬光電這個拉回目前整理在所有均線附近我覺得也是不錯那南亞部分剛剛已經有講過了就是它的不管在本業上或者是業外上面表現都非常的漂亮
尤其是在明年南亞科對它貢獻
還是會非常的大
因為它材料端
所以也是什麼套餐用到的材料
它都有在研發對不對
因為它是一貫廠
它在就上游來講的話
它是很純的一貫廠
所以南亞空間應該還是有
那再來市場上會問說
那PCB怎麼辦
就是有很多
其實PTFE族群非常大
太多廠商了
有一些位階現在還很低的
不曉得它跟PTFE的關聯
或者是也許現在
沒有什麼大的關聯
而股價卻已經跌得稀利化了
因為這一波PCB修正的蠻明顯的
其實我覺得多多少少受到PTFE影響
你覺得有
可是很多觀眾搞不好
今天才真正認識這件事
其實多多少少有
因為PTFE這件事情
它會讓PCB的加工難度提高
成本會有些提高
又是成本的問題
對 所以市場上會有些稍微有些擔心
可是我剛剛有提到說
這件事情它不是絕對的
去完完全全的去導入
它還有中間的過渡的空間
可以來去讓市場做期待
所以這些PCB公司
因為股價已經修正很多
但是他們自己的題材非常棒
對 大家覺得我本益比
相對之下很合理
可是就是長不起來
到底問題是什麼
比如說以8155博之來講
它在IPC的PCB上面
因為這個是高毛利的PCB
公控用的
在下半年即將會開始放量
所以我覺得這個修正也一大段了
大家可以多做留意
那金像鏈部分就不用多說了
那真的是龍頭機有神
上半年已經賺了16塊
我覺得也是因為不用多說
所以很多觀眾留言到後來已經生氣了
就到底怎樣
它不是龍頭嗎
對 當然第二季的毛利率
有稍微低一點點
可是我覺得它第二季的毛利率
其實不如預期的幅度
比市場還要來的輕
所以它還蠻厲害的
對 其實它已經算相對棒
那只要第三季 第四季的
這個產品組合有上來的話
它的這個毛利率
還有機會去挑戰新高
所以我覺得龍頭廠
還是一樣可以持續關注
好 等於這兩檔
它現在在陳前
反而是價值的彰顯
未來是有機會往上的
好 最後復古一下
來考考余城了
當時我們有做了
三個教學單元
基本面 技術面 籌碼面
都有做
分別是什麼
記得 一定記得了
純古Debug 古余老師
歌友 籌碼 全鎮小哥
朱老師的
什麼
標股在線等啦
標股在線等
說實話點閱率非常高
非常謝謝朱老師
很佛心的一系列
現在我們有把
後來于晨不在的一些片段
剪輯放在我們的會員頻道
也希望大家多多支持
以及請大家多多支持
不會投顧的于晨
我們的老戰友
非常謝謝你今天來
謝謝蔡
很開心看到于晨
現在是一個成熟的分析師
希望大家也多多支持他
他過去擅長的領域
是專研PCB
當然接下來整體的科技發展
它也會幫我們持續帶來最新的知識
剛剛講到輝達的新機
現在大家想的已經不是VIA Rubin了
是VIA Rubin Ultra
接下來的PCB的規格發展
但不要太擔心
有最新的材料
但還有它的難度
所以台廠各自在自己擅長的領域
組成了套餐組合
各自有選擇
當然喜歡標的
終於知道台虹雅電在標什麼了
但是穩的我們的龍頭台光電也全都有
至於好像沒有受惠程度那麼多
可是股價未接卻是相對合理
這邊一併幫大家做了完整解讀
今天非常謝謝三位的粉絲來到現場
今天台股這個網上中
給了大家不少氣勢上的信心
而自然我們看到創新高的公司
都是跟AI相關的
晚上我們也密切觀察一下
回答財報公布後的結果
那也希望今天理財答案秀
對你投資有幫助喔
明天再會了 拜拜